no
[Música]
y ahora pondremos a algunos tipos en un
helicóptero y nos iremos afganistán
mañana sabemos cómo invadir países por
desgracia
pakistaní va a tener que aceptar esta
nueva situación están con nosotros o los
mandamos de vuelta a la edad de piedra
olivo o muchos animales murieron pero la
mayoría se dispersaron dispersa
a dónde fueron
[Música]
los escombros siguen ardiendo menos de
10 días después de los atentados del 11
de septiembre jacques chirac es el
primer jefe de estado extranjero que
visita el lugar
una visita largamente planificada que el
presidente de eeuu quiso mantener el
mensaje es claro eeuu sigue afectado
pero sigue en pie
[Aplausos]
chirac le dijo al presidente
estadounidense del principio que
estábamos dispuestos a darle toda
nuestra ayuda el presidente iraquí le
dijo al presidente bush sólo hay una
cosa que no puede pedirme y son las
operaciones
es decir los asesinatos selectivos el
presidente bush estaba muy sorprendido
y
no hay ninguna sensación de que esta
administración vaya a utilizar este
horror para llevar a cabo guerras a gran
escala o para lanzarse a aventuras
militares pero claramente quiero decir
cuando uno conoce al presidente bush un
poco quiere decir claramente que este
era un asunto que los estadounidenses
iban a manejar ellos mismos era evidente
rápidamente se vislumbra una operación
en afganistán es en ese país gobernado
por los talibanes donde al qaeda ha
establecido su base de retaguardia
eeuu se dirige primero a su vecino
pakistán dirigido por el general
mucharraz
es uno de los únicos países del mundo
que apoya a los talibanes para mantener
cierto control sobre el país
de este modo islamabad está comprando la
paz en su lado occidental
mientras las tensiones son recurrentes
con indian el oriente
el 11 de septiembre de 2001 el general
mahmud ahmadi jefe de la inteligencia
militar paquistaní visitó washington
y
vino a verme y quiso explicarme que
tenía que entender la historia de los
talibanes y todo eso y le dije no
general la historia comienza hoy y estas
son seis o siete demandas que el
secretario powell y yo escribimos
nosotros mismos en el papel
y le dije por favor póngase en contacto
con el presidente musharraf hablé con él
sobre esto
winnie gesell san bernabé y es maybe y
eso es
y
necesitamos sí a todas ellas estaba muy
enfadado conmigo y pude ver que era
reacio lo llevé a mi despacho donde
tenía expuesta una estrella de pakistán
un galardón que me concedieron durante
la guerra soviética por apoyar a los
muyaidines de pakistán y le dije sabe
qué es esto y dijo por supuesto es la
estrella paquisha me contestó así es
que si no accede a nuestras demandas
ningún estadounidense volverá a recibir
uno de estos se lo prometo al día
siguiente vino y dijo que el presidente
musharraf estaba de acuerdo con todo
ambos la versión que ha dado el general
musharraf es que el mensaje que le
transmitió el general mahmud fue que
estuviera con nosotros solo bombardear y
amos hasta la edad de piedra
y en los meses siguientes puedo decir
que mi relación con el isi el servicio
de inteligencia pakistaní dio un giro de
180 grados todo lo que queríamos con
respecto a al qaeda
nos lo daban y coopera vamos muy
estrechamente por esas mismas reglas no
se aplican hasta granos
los servicios de inteligencia
estadounidenses han conseguido ponerse
en contacto con el mulá osmany adjunto
del mulá omar el fundador de los
talibanes robert de liniers el jefe de
la estación de la cia en la región va a
su encuentro
el espía quiere convencerlo de que
suelte ávila link
e hizo algo que nunca había visto hacer
a un líder tribal pastún tomó el
turbante y lo puso en la mesa a su lado
y parecía desesperado porque sabía el
desastre que les iba a ocurrir si
entraban en guerra con eeuu
y me dijo dígame qué debo hacer así que
le dije mire sabemos que el mulá omar no
puede por muchas razones no puedes
romper con bin laden pero usted puede
hacer lo que el mulá omar no puede nadie
dice que haya que cazar al mulá omar
pero hay que ponerlo bajo arresto
domiciliario tiene que hacer
inmediatamente una declaración pública
diciendo lo que está haciendo y por qué
necesita reunir al resto de la unidad
ciudad y por supuesto pasamos por todo
esto básicamente como se lanza un golpe
de estado
y él me escuchó dijo de acuerdo lo haré
y fue como si se quitara un peso de
encima se subió a su vehículo y se fue
de vuelta a kandahar así que esperaba
contra toda experiencia que su
determinación sobreviviera al viaje
alcanzado pero temía que no lo hiciera y
de hecho no lo hizo
al no poder convencer a los talibanes de
que abandonen a al qaeda washington se
está preparando para sacarlos del poder
por la fuerza donald rumsfeld el
secretario de defensa pone en marcha el
pentágono para preparar la ofensiva pero
los militares dicen que el largo tiempo
de preparación para involucrarse en un
país tan remoto y complicado no les
permite actuar con la rapidez que le
gustaría a georges david buss
rooms él estaba furioso con el ejército
por no ser capaz de llevar a afganistán
fuerzas terrestres importantes a tiempo
kabul está a punto de caer y no tenemos
a nadie allí de garcía heredia edwards
en la silla a la que lidera pongamos
algunos hombres en un helicóptero y
volvemos a plan esta mañana no importa
no necesitamos a cientos de hombres
famosa y he hecho así fue como empezó la
invasión como todo el mundo sabe ahora
el viejo helicóptero ruso y unos ocho
tipos de la cia y volando con bolsas de
dinero para hablar por un grupo de
líderes que vale
afortunadamente habíamos mantenido
contacto a lo largo de los años
pero cuando las tribus locales opuestas
a los talibanes ven maletas llenas de
dólares de la cia y luego llegan las
fuerzas especiales estadounidenses
comprenden que washington está decidido
a llegar hasta el final
los combates se inician con el apoyo
aéreo estadounidense bombardeando las
posiciones de los talibanes la alianza
del norte progresa rápidamente el
movimiento del famoso comandante masud
asesinado dos días antes del 11-s
incluso se sintió con alas y decidió sin
luz verde de los estadounidenses entrar
a kabul la capital
denis rafter en no decir que está
levantando de budán kabul se había
convertido en un lugar de odio basado en
las actividades injustas que los
talibanes habían realizado durante años
y si no hubiéramos entrado a kabul la
gente podría haber querido vengarse y
podría haber sido un baño de sangre al
final
así que tuvimos que entrar en kabul y
asegurarnos de que los talibanes no
pudieran volver a entrar en el país
la operación militar con el ejército y
la cia que derrotó los talibanes y tomo
kabul es probablemente la operación
militar estadounidense más brillante
desde la segunda guerra mundial en mi
opinión está bien hecho muy pocos
estadounidenses el poder aéreo
estadounidense usa aliados tribales y
los talibanes están destruidos
el comienzo fue bastante sencillo
sabemos como invadir países por
desgracia
los miembros de al-qaeda se han
refugiado en las montañas afganas la
casa blanca quiere evitar un vacío de
poder y que el país caiga en el caos
varios estados extranjeros aceptan la
intervención militar en afganistán
jacques chirac en particular mantiene su
palabra pero él y su primer ministro
lionel jospin siguen siendo muy
cautelosos
[Música]
po licencia
en su mayor parte atacaremos con
nuestros aviones desde un portaaviones
que hemos desplegado en el mediterráneo
durante un tiempo desplegamos fuerzas
especiales
pero en su mayor parte de acuerdo con el
presidente de la republica de entonces
limitamos nuestras intervenciones a
asegurar nuestra embajada y la sede de
la onu en kabul
que ha sido reabierta 6 de nations
uniacc kabul
gobierno al menos mientras esté en el
gobierno hasta el 2002
no entraremos en la espiral militar
afgana
hay que decir que varios países no
estaban allí para luchar
hay países y pienso en particular en
alemania que fue una de las dificultades
que tuvimos con ellos pero no solo
alemania tenían restricciones de empleo
seamos honestos en afganistán los
soldados de la otan están un poco en
segundo plano para los estadounidenses
era importante demostrar que no estaban
solas que no se trataba de una invasión
estadounidense que todo el occidente
civilizado estaba detrás de eeuu
algunos aprovechan la calma tras la
caída del talibán para comprometerse
mínimamente pérez una calma precaria la
que reina en afganistán
en 2002 2003 y después de 2004 la
situación fue mejorando se podía viajar
desde aquí a cualquier parte del país no
había ningún distrito bajo el control
talibán
y todos le quitamos el ojo de encima
y algunos en la administración a
mediados de 2002 empezaron a pensar en
irak y pusimos afganistán francamente en
piloto automático
y dirigimos nuestra atención a irak y
dejamos afganistán a la deriva
ante este estudio
rezo muchos talibanes murieron pero la
mayoría fueron expresados que disperse
las
personas
la pregunta que nadie se ha planteado
seriamente a dónde fueron dónde están
no han desaparecido eso es lo que estaba
diciendo además los soldados dijeron
pero los talibanes para nosotros salimos
por la mañana de patrulla vemos a los
afganos en el campo saludando nos
etcétera con actitud amistosa al volver
por la noche la misma gente había
empuñado armas y nos disparaba qué
diferencia hay los talibanes también son
afganos y se mezclan completamente con
la población
cada año la seguridad se deteriora un
poco más cuando llegó a la casa blanca a
principios de 2009 barack obama heredó
una situación especialmente preocupante
tras muchas dudas sobre si involucrarse
en un conflicto del que quería salir el
nuevo presidente estadounidense decidió
golpear con fuerza para poner fin a la
insurrección
barack obama envió 30.000 soldados a
afganistán y dijo dentro de 18 meses nos
retiraremos ok esto es obviamente una
cosa ridícula es decir no los envíe o
enviar los civiles que vuelvan a casa
cuando terminen el trabajo
en total más de 100.000 soldados
estadounidenses y decenas de miles de
tropas de la otan están desplegados en
el país pero los talibanes no les
importa 18 meses más continúa en sus
numerosos ataques a los soldados
extranjeros saben que estas tropas se
irán un día a diferencia de ellos sobre
todo porque la gente en washington se
está dando cuenta poco a poco de que los
paquistaníes les están diciendo a los
estadounidenses lo que quieren oír y
admirar abc para que estaban están
permítanme decir que pakistán ha tomado
una decisión meditada de formar parte de
la coalición de estar con eeuu para
luchar contra el terrorismo en todos sus
frentes dondequiera que exista my way
words
por supuesto que si estaban jugando un
doble juego estaban haciendo lo
suficiente para quitarse encima los
estadounidenses y a la vez obtener ayuda
de eeuu ciertos elementos de las fuerzas
armadas de pakistán estaban apoyando a
los talibanes
pero si lo miran desde su perspectiva se
estaban protegiendo porque no podían
estar seguros de lo que les depararía el
futuro
el 100% de la cooperación nunca vino de
pakistán y el error de la administración
mucho fue pensar que sería un proceso
gradual estaban contentos con el 30 40
por ciento de cooperación al principio y
luego con un 50 por ciento nunca
entendieron que mientras no estuviera al
cien por ciento el problema volvería a
surgir
el problema es que somos occidentales y
yo tendería a decir que precisamente
nuestra visión es la capital es la
construcción de un estado en el estado
central y ese es el tipo de modelo que
conocemos y tenemos y no somos capaces
de impulsar otro modelo
la gente dice porque no podemos ganar la
guerra en afganistán yo os digo que
ganaron la guerra en afganistán a los 5
meses de iniciada todos sus objetivos se
han cumplido y todos y entonces se les
ocurrió un nuevo plan para convertir a
afganistán en la suiza de ac central
pero la administración bush está
descuidando la reconstrucción del país
especialmente la económica al principio
del conflicto sólo gastaba 52 dólares
per cápita frente a los 814 dólares de
kosovo con los 1.390 dólares de bosnia
unos años antes si button es aquel
cáncer
si le dan a alguien un arma y le dices
que trabaja para el estado pero no puede
alimentar a sus hijos que esperan
a cabo actuamos donde
finalmente se ve casi obligado a
utilizar su rifle para alimentar a sus
hijos
esta es una cuestión muy importante que
se plantea en muchos países del tercer
mundo no hay que ir más lejos torcer
[Música]
y
ah
[Música]